[Applaudissements]
les admirateurs de la légende du hockey
jean béliveau pourront bientôt mettre la
main sur ses derniers souvenirs sans
bail patins médailles trophées la
famille de jean béliveau a décidé cinq
ans après sa mort de vendre au plus
offrant les derniers objets de la
collection de l'ancien capitaine du
canadien de montréal
parmi les pièces maîtresses qui seront
offertes à l'encan jusqu'au 25 février
il ya une bague de la coupe stanley de
1959 et le trophée art ross remis à jean
béliveau en 1956 à titre du meilleur
pointeur de la ligue nationale de hockey
en tout 80 lots seront offerts aux
collectionneurs des pièces les moins
chères des images de gracier seront
affichés à 200 dollars une première
vente avait eu lieu en 2005 et avait
rapporté près d'un million de dollars
[Musique]